et avec nous sur ce plateau jean de
gliniasty directeur de recherche à
l'iris ans et l'ambassadeur de france en
russie et auteurs de ce livre
géopolitique de la russie c'est aux
éditions eyrolles bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation quel est selon
vous le signal envoyé avec la nomination
de michael amis louches chine à la tête
du gouvernement russe
alors je dirais que le président russe a
à coeur de de créer un nouveau contrat
social moral et politique avec la
population russe en fait quand on
regarde l'histoire il ya eu en fait deux
contrats jusqu'à présent un contrat
moral en quelque sorte un contrat qui
était fondée sur le développement de la
russie le redressement de la russie à
partir des années a fait dans les années
2000 et ensuite à partir de crise
ukrainienne un contrat fondé sur la
restitution de son statut de grande
puissance à la russie qui maintenant on
n'exerce plus ses effets compte tenu des
difficultés sociales qui existent en
russie et donc maintenant c'est un
troisième contrat qu'à travers ce
gouvernement
le président veut fonder j'ajouterai que
le système constitutionnel russe qui est
très proche du système constitutionnel
français avec un président et un premier
ministre qui sert de fusible en fait
c'est en fait le juriste français guy
carcassonne qui a contribué avec
d'autres à la constitution de 93 en
russie cette constitution permet
justement en cours de mandat
présidentiel de changer de premier
ministre qui sert de fusible pour
instaurer un nouveau contrat politique
avec la population alors on l'a dit la
nomination de michael michou steam va
être approuvé en va être soumise à
l'approbation de la douma dans les
prochaines heures
dans la foulée il va évidemment
constitué un gouvernement est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à ce qu'il y ait de
nouveaux venus dans ce gouvernement car
je pense que oui parce que je crois que
monsieur michu sting lui-même annoncé
qu'il y aurait des changements
et puis comme c'est une nouvelle phase
toute façon il faudra de nouvelles têtes
nécessairement pas tout mais il faudra
changer quelques têtes et pour
l'opposition qu'est ce que ça peut
changer
alors ça dépend si vous parlez de
l'opposition dans le système ou un
système pour l'opposition un système je
pense pas que ça change grand chose à ce
stade pour les peuples opposition intra
système ça permet quand même des débats
plus ça permettra parce que l'enjeu est
évidemment c'est le référendum
constitutionnel en anglais et la réforme
n'aura pas lieu avant septembre
donc pour l'instant ça ne change rien
mais ce sont les les réformes
constitutionnelles qui vont changer
quelque chose à terme
et justement cette révision de la
constitution vladimir poutine l'a donc
annoncé hier devant les députés les
sénateurs russes étaient donc quelques
heures avant que ne démissionnent
dimitri medvedev de son poste de chef du
gouvernement ainsi que son gouvernement
qu'est ce qui a motivé le président
russe dans cette décision de réformer la
constitution
alors il l'a fait du contexte économique
social le contexte économique et social
j'ai l'impression que et la population
russe
maintenant ma tâche moins d'importance
au succès diplomatiques russo succès
militait à la syrie la libye le la scène
internationale et plus centré sur les
difficultés économiques comme on le sait
le pouvoir d'achat a baissé depuis
quatre ans déjà des premières mesures
ont été prises avec l'accent mis dans le
budget sur les dépenses sociales
éducatives et santé pour l'essentiel il
ya eu des revalorisations de retraite de
salaires mais manifestement maintenant
la priorité du gouvernement russe c'est
le social dans cette réforme de la
constitution
la principale mesure qui a été annoncée
vise donc à renforcer le rôle du
parlement dont la formation du
gouvernement en lui donnant notamment la
prérogative d'élire le premier ministre
que le président sera là obligé de
nommer ce qu elle équilibre des pouvoirs
va être modifiée en russie qu'est ce que
ça signifie concrètement bel équilibre
de pouvoir sera sans doute modifié mais
ça va être très très progressif
d'abord on ne sait pas encore ce qu'il
y'a pas ce qu'est un comité de
préparation de la réforme
constitutionnelle qui va être convoquées
bientôt
il est clair que jusque là il faut le
dire le la douma était plutôt une
chambre d'enregistrement et voir une
chambre d'amplification des décisions
présidentielles très souvent on a vu la
douma j'avais bien en faire plus là
maintenant il y aura de vrais débats à
l'admr et moi je ne connais pas et
personne n'a encore la substance mais il
est clair que le pouvoir législatif
méritait d'être un peu regonflé alors là
d'un film n'a pas le droit de se
représenter à la fin de son mandat est
ce que avec l'annoncé de cette réforme
la constitution à ce que le président
russe prépare l'après 2024 alors vous
voyez qui prépare l'après 2024 ça c'est
sûr ça c'est sûr simplement la femme que
ça prendra à ce stade personne ne le
sait donc certains annoncent que le
président russe prépare un prochain
mandat pour lui-même
d'autres disent qu'il y aura d'autres
candidats personne ne sait ce qui va se
passer
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage jean
de gliniasty directeur de recherche à
l'iris enseigne ambassadeur de france en
russie je rappelle le titre de votre
dernier ouvrage géopolitique de la
russie 7 aux éditions eyrolles
merci